[Musik]
lukas auf die ziehung gibt nur college
der coach
das ist martina fuchs ein aushängeschild
des chinesischen staatsfernsehens
und sie ist schweizerin gags und das drk
in diesem film geht es um ehrgeiz
karriere und kommunistische propaganda
[Musik]
das ist pekings wahrzeichen das neue
hochhaus des chinesischen
staatsfernsehens cctv von hier sendet
die kommunistische partei ihre
propaganda in die ganze welt
hier arbeitet martina fuchs
als erstes ausländisches fernsehteam
dürfen wir hier filmen
martina kann türen öffnen die uns sonst
verschlossen bleiben
der chinesische staatssender scheint
stolz zu sein auf sein schweizer gesicht
ganz im gegenteil zu uns
auslandskorrespondenten genießt sie hier
großes ansehen sie bringt dem land ruhm
wir sind im land eher lästig die zehnte
etage ist matthias reich hier ist die
nachrichtenzentrale des
englischsprachigen nachrichtensenders e
tv news von hier aus soll die welt
erfahren wie china tickt
martina hat hier eine sonderrolle
auf den ersten blick macht sie den job
einer normalen fernsehjournalistin
täglich präsentiert sich die
wirtschaftsnachrichten der sendung
global business sendung interviewt sie
wirtschaftsbosse staatspräsidenten oder
andere mächtige menschen dieser welt
die sendung hat zuschauerzahlen von
denen wir nur träumen können
martina stellt uns ihren kollegen
charles young vor
der starmoderator hat nur gute worte
übrig für die schweizerin
ausländische journalisten sind bei uns
willkommen
wir mögen ihre außensicht auf china
einige sind da sehr voreingenommen und
haben eine sehr eingeschränkte sicht und
berichten sehr sarkastisch martina geht
aber viel weiter
wir wissen zwar nicht was wirklich in
ihrem herzen vorgeht und wie sie
wirklich fühlt in ihrer arbeit ist sie
aber sehr genau
sie kann alles sie schreibt schneidet
berichtet und führt regie sie ist
allmächtig sie kann einfach alles
ich werde gleich rot so kollegial das
verhältnis auch scheint es gibt klare
grenzen in diesem newsroom kritik an der
politik der kommunistischen partei ist
unerwünscht
vom lausche vor ein älterer herr oder
frau der abgesegnet werden
das aktuellen stimmt ob er eventuell
nicht viel kritik und reagieren
es gibt aber man darf doch gut die
balance zu bringen mit ihren 32 jahren
hat martina schon viel erreicht sie
spricht neun sprachen fließend darunter
arabisch israeli und selbstverständlich
auch mandarin nach einem abschluss in
internationalen beziehungen zog es sie
in den mittleren osten wo sie bei
reuters ihre journalistischen sporen
abverdient seit vier jahren arbeitet sie
nun in china beim staatsfernsehen
und auch da falls sie weiter an ihrer
karriere
und für diese karriere fährt martina
auch tief in die provinz chinas die
kleinstadt sony ist das herz des roten
tourismus millionen stramme kommunisten
pilgern jedes jahr hierher um den
parteigründer mao zedong und seiner
kommunistischen partei zu huldigen
hier treffen wir martina und ihr team
wieder
ich bin beeindruckt von der größe ihrer
filmcrew
an dem ort wo man damals einen langen
marsch begann beginnt heute martinas
drehtag
ihr chef der regisseur zeigt er die
wichtigste pilgerstätte des moguls damit
nichts schief läuft bespricht der
regisseur mit martina noch einmal punkt
für punkt den drehplan
er hält die fäden fest in der hand von
diesem skript soll martina möglichst
nicht abweichen
in diesem haus übernahm mao zedong
erstmals offiziell die führung der roten
armee und sein aufstieg zum großen
parteiführer nahm seinen lauf
hier begann der lange kampf gegen seine
politischen gegner die kommentar schritt
für schritt folgt martina den
anweisungen des regisseurs
sie gibt sich beeindruckt ab so viel
historischem pathos
doch ganz geheuer scheint es auch hier
nicht dabei politik überhaupt geholt das
ist erst mal politische theorie
sozusagen mitmachen wenn ich mich immer
ganz klar distanzieren die
kommunistische partei am hut mit der
gierig wenn ich mich auch ganz klar
zurückhalten und ich bin journalistin
business sehr programm kubisten psystars
und noch mal wissen über finanzen und
der wirtschaft bricht es ist brauch
nicht sowohl ist sony ziehe mit der er
ganz filme kommunisten
china hat längst gelernt in wichtigen
momenten gute miene zum bösen spiel zu
machen
sie arbeitet nicht zum ersten mal in
einem land mit einem autoritären regime
ihre karriere will sie aber nicht mit
allzu viel kritik gefährden
sie zeigt sich interessiert an der
kultur des gastlandes kommunistische
partei so der kommentar
das ist davis vor
ja ich bin mit schweiz aufgewachsen aber
die haben ja mittlerweile spitze
verpasste weil ich habe eine sehr viele
länder vor allem im nahen osten jemen
syrien ägypten und die montan und
mittlerweile in sprache kann aber auch
chinesisch ist die schwierigste aber mit
arabisch verglichen zum beispiel boni
fließen
weil der regisseur ruft es geht weiter
martinas nächster programmpunkt wartet
schon der semesterbeginn der
pädagogischen universität von sony wie
in china üblich beginnt das studium
erstmal mit zwei monaten militär
training martina sieht in diesen jungen
frauen und männern die florierende
zukunft der region
alles muss stimmen wenn martin arbeitet
alles muss kontrolliert sein
ist martina selbstkritisch ja ja sie
sind die arbeit braucht manchmal mehrere
anläufe die hsg immer perfekt sein
martina ist immer auf sendung
und schon ist das foto gepostet
martinas programmen geht weiter wie
immer nach dem plan der regisseure
[Musik]
doch dann passiert ein austausch student
aus afrika taucht plötzlich auf
sprachtalent martina ist sofort wieder
auf sendung
diesmal auf martinas spontanität wird
kurzerhand den kommunistischen drehplan
über den haufen
martina hat es geschafft
weißt du was der herr ist ein austausch
student studiert hier marxismus nur ein
kurzes statement zehn sekunden geht es
um den langen marsch
ja klar er studiert kultur und sprachen
das wird lustig 8 sekunden
doch der regisseur bleibt skeptisch das
ist zu viel propaganda wenn wir nur den
langen marsch zeigen
matthias aufbäumen gegen die propaganda
hat funktioniert zumindest hier im feld
im fernsehen wird die szene dann
allerdings nicht ausgestrahlt
es wird abend wir genießen die ersten
minuten ohne anweisungen eines
kommunistischen regisseurs trotzdem so
scheint es mir fällt es martina nicht
einfach abzuschalten
selbst mit knurrendem magen behält sie
ihr sende bewusstsein
die fernsehfrau fällt nie aus ihrer
rolle
was ist das ist das ein und das hier
kartoffeln ist das lecker in peking
haben wir sowas nicht häppchen für
häppchen platziert sie ihre kommentare
zu essen land und leute eine moderatorin
kommentiert ihr eigenes leben darstellt
dass die bank für sich
martina ist eine sauerei eine langnase
sie genießt ihre rolle als die immer
perfekt geschminkte ausländer kennen sie
vom fernsehen ja sie haben mich schon
gesehen sie weiß ich immer zu verkaufen
wenn man muss auch immer ein super focus
heimler form ist raus
zielstrebig die und sein plan war und
zeige dass zwar spreche seiner frau und
seiner familie
aber das kommt den schuh ich bin ja man
muss auch im plan h und denn auch
familie stammte
in china kann sich vorstellen ein
chinese
die familie sei ja schon wichtig erzählt
mir martina deshalb letztlich auch ein
ihre eigene familie in der schweiz zu
besuchen
so wechseln wir denn von chinas provinz
in die schweizer provinz
das ist martinas heimatstadt 20.000
einwohner aus chinesischer sicht ein
dorf zwei dreimal im jahr besucht
martina hier ihre eltern heute hat sie
eine arbeitskollegin aus china
mitgenommen
es scheint fast als hätte sich aarau
noch mehr herausgeputzt als martina
selber martina mag keine zufälle peking
lieber behält sie die kontrolle über ihr
leben und das ihres umfelds die eltern
haben sich längst an den tatendrang
ihrer tochter gewöhnt sie kennen sie
nicht anders ich höre der hand freut das
ist natürlich hat dann und wann
mit frack und das alles gut sie managt
sich selber und sie mein star ihren job
ausgezeichnet nachbarn nämlich aber warm
ständig wachsendes unternehmen an land
oder in der stadt laut luftverschmutzung
so häufig dann macht einen das natürlich
gleich nach der kantonsschule verließ
martina fürs studium
seither ist sie auf achse das hat immer
möglich stetig im dessauer möglich stück
bis monatlich machen und was sie denn
nach der matur ruf kämpfen ich weiß das
ist das klar sie wird ihren weg machen
aber möglichst bis sehr thema zeit schön
aber nie langweilig glaube sie sind mal
wieder zurück und genieße die psyche ab
länger wird es nicht um seiten und
matthias maasch dauert schon lange und
mir wird immer klarer
sie lässt sich von nichts und niemandem
aufhalten weder von ihren eltern noch
von der gefahr sich vor den karren der
chinesischen propaganda spannen zu
lassen
ob ich zum schluss ist einfach ein
instrument votiert ich einfach am
schluss
am anfang habe ich danke ich bin doch
wahrscheinlich nummer als
aushängeschilder für teenager und würde
was mich benützt als propaganda maschine
das will ich sie denn habe ich aber
feststellt nach mehreren monaten das gar
nicht dass sie eigentlich ein export
ausländische spezialisten für das gebiet
von journalismus und eigentlich
innerhalb der kanal die fernsehstation
weiter zu entwickeln mit ihnen zusammen
schaffen und inhalte blau zum
kulturellen verständnis betragen
martina sieht sich als brückenbauerin
zwischen dem westen und dem osten
wir gehen zurück ins zentrum von chinas
propaganda in wenigen minuten beginnt
ihre live sendung wie immer muss alles
perfekt sein
zumindest nach außen
ich ganz sicher ob sie sind mein
geschäft das will ich nicht wahnsinnig
das ist eine fast denn eigentlich aber
im fahrzeug und der visuellen und ums
bild immer lampenfieber hat martina
längst nicht mehr live sendungen vor 100
millionen zuschauern bringen die
aargauerin nicht mehr aus der fassung
sie denkt bereits an den nächsten
karriereschritt wenn alles nach plan
läuft wird sie peking bald verlassen
denn chinas staatssender hat die junge
schweizerin mit einer neuen großen
aufgabe betraut martina fuchs soll in
london ein neues außenbüro für sie wie
aufbauen und dort
wirtschaftskorrespondentin werden
martinas langer marsch geht also weiter
[Musik]